all right Rachel
Rachel where are you from where'd you
grow up
um I grew up in Johnston Rhode Island
but I spent uh my teen years and I
graduated from burville Rhode Island
and uh I don't really move around a lot
but um
uh definitely
didn't like either one of them honestly
tell me about your family
um
so I have a mom and a dad
two sisters that are 14 and 13 years
older than I am and I have a baby sister
I do have step siblings but those are
like predominantly by Blood I guess
um
when I say I have my parents I feel like
a lot of people
um
have this mindset of being grateful no
matter what kind of parent they are
and that in an understanding I
completely understand why people would
think that but it really wasn't the case
I guess
um my mom was an opiate addict
my dad and her met when they were like
31 and she was perfectly fine they lived
in the same building
and my dad was an immigrant from Mexico
and had no idea how to speak any English
whatsoever
so my mom taught him she had two girls
of her own
and I think she was fascinated with a
man who was the same age as her honestly
because like
my sister's dad was 52. when my mom gave
birth to them and she was like 19.
and apparently he knew her before that
age so I feel like my mom was really
really infatuated with someone
you know that worked and did things he
may not have spoken English but he he
still tried to be the role model that
she wanted
but I feel like she was a bit blindsided
with the fact that like
the two men liked small children
I mean what do you have in common when
you're 52 with a 19 year old would you
have in common with a child with a
different mindset besides being a
fatherly figure
so I wasn't really surprised when my dad
molested my sister
I was a baby
uh my mom had no idea
I think she was a bit tricked into you
know
having me
like she really didn't know what a Visa
or citizenship really was
my mom took her siblings when she was
like 13 and found my sister's dad and
tried to make something out of nothing
you know
so I feel terrible thinking about it
and I dodged her a lot for it because
after she died I
I never understood why she did some of
the things that she did
when she told my mom that my dad
molested her she didn't believe her
like at all
and my dad was like I'll take Rachel if
you don't believe me
and I think at that point like all my
life I've tried to like stand back from
the painting and like look at the whole
picture because I feel a little selfish
looking at the one part of them that I
knew I feel like I never healed that way
but like I'm sure she looked at my dad
and was like What if this man's actually
telling the truth right what if he's a
good man and my daughter is just lying
so my sister was sent away for a very
long time like she was like 13 or 14
when it happened and I never saw my
sister again like and if I did it was
for like 20 minutes inside of a Butler
Hospital
you know of course like she could have
gotten better but she didn't
and my dad just she was so she was sent
where she was sent to like Butler
Hospital which is a which is a like a
mental facility and it was there she was
there for a while she I think till this
day can't really hold down a job
and like at one point like I don't blame
her because no one believed her
she was molested before by her uncles so
I'm sure by time now if you don't do
that healing you turn into like a
monster
and my dad just went off and you know
she was out of the picture and he could
hand her with me
I didn't get my memories until after my
son was born
so like I spent a lot of my childhood
idolizing this man like I loved this man
I did everything I could to be like this
man
I wanted to be everything like my
parents you know even if my mom was an
opiate addict you know the earliest
memories of her I could imagine was like
she was obviously always on pills and
she slept a lot and she had these like
giant bins
and I obviously had no idea what like
Klonopins were because she was like it
was like a fat woman she gained so much
weight when she was pregnant with me and
after that like she couldn't move
so like she would send me
to go make cocktails for her uh bottles
with like shapes and stuff on it so I
could help her like get through the day
and my dad did that and I at all he was
molesting me and teaching me things
gifting me them you know those amazing
presents like a bike and toys and
guitars that no one would ever play with
me with I was just to sit there
you know my parents were born in the 60s
like 1961 both of them so I feel like
their generation as long as you survived
you were okay what happened in between
that story like that's debatable you
know that's really debatable you know
you could come out with trauma
and he'll nail never like
he'll never man up to it
ever
and it haunts me because he
when my mom died I feel very selfish and
I've always kept it in so this is like
the first time that I'm actually really
saying it is she was so sick man
she barely walked I watched up dialysis
like my nana went through it and my mom
was getting sick more sick because she
missed her mom that I
I watched her die I watched her Strokes
I watched her almost like the couch on
fire from smoking cigarettes if she did
go out
it was it was hell on Earth because you
can tell she was physically in pain
so when she was dying I was
I was hoping for it
because no person should live that way
and I was disgusted with my dad
oh it's man who I idolized and Love
watched his partner die
watched her
crumble and he thought nothing of it he
thought nothing nothing of it so hard
that he got married six months later and
we moved
now he says I had some kind of saying in
that
but he wasn't telling me that
he was meeting up with a woman that I
knew from like my childhood
we used to go camping my mom she really
didn't do much but she really liked to
go camping and she would go with this
she would always meet up with other
people and this man who played the
guitar
his daughter became my stepmom
and I feel like being traumatized she
was not relevant to my story until she
became my stepmom
and after that it was like a whole new
hell on Earth and that's when we moved
to Burrillville
because after you know the first eight
people that my dad molested he needed to
leave he couldn't stay in Johnston he
molested all of my friends when they
went Elementary School age
like
and I'm over here talking to CPS like my
dad's a great guy like I promise he's
never done that
meanwhile I had yeast infections and all
those like little signs
that I was abused
so like after she died he wanted a man I
wasn't allowed to mourn I became angry I
moved to Burrillville and Hell began
the only control I could ever have was
lying and stealing and now that I'm
older of course I'm embarrassed by it
of course I'm embarrassed by it but I
had no control
I had no control over anything and I
also didn't remember anything
I was living in a house with the person
that told me he loved me who taught me
how to give a and then also
watched my mom die
and I was supposed to be okay with it
and the worst part is I try to connect
to like my older sisters
thinking I could connect with her
because I was feeling weird and she's my
oldest sister and she was the coolest
one too like she had tongue piercings
and tattoos
she's the reason I have a tongue
piercing and she is such a mean son of a
she's so traumatized and I vowed
and promised myself that I wouldn't
become her because I have a baby sister
now
and I know that if I fall into the wrong
mindset I could 100 destroy that like
how she destroyed me
she's mean she can't sit in the same
room with me for more than 10 minutes
without telling me how much I look like
him
telling me how much I should have you
know I must have enjoyed being molested
because I don't visually look like I'm
distraught and angry and sad
but like you weren't there when I was
you know I had a child
like that was that was the best moment
and the worst moment of my entire life
was having my son
it was terrible and it was awesome it
was like on one hand I had this
beautiful little boy that's so awesome
and he's like autistic and he's so smart
I feel like I you know gave birth to
like a Bobby Hill and Sheldon and he's
so awesome
and on the other hand I feel like life
watched me get so excited it like picked
me up
they put me on a table and they spread
me like a little frog and I took out
every one of my little organs and said
you see this
this is all the trauma you get to unpack
you make sure it goes back in safely
soundly and you can like survive after
this
and I had no idea that I was going to
remember
I wasn't able to connect with my kid it
was so hard I had bad postpartum I felt
like a failure of a mom because every
time I try to breastfeed or or be close
it felt so terrible and I felt guilty I
didn't know what to do when he cried I
wasn't I wasn't made to be a mom I
didn't know how to care I loved him I
wanted him but like
I was so stunted in my trauma that I had
to really unpack it
really unpack it
to the father
um I was someone I dated in high school
a um
we aren't we're not meant to be we were
meant to be parents to Scott we co-exist
nicely but it's been a path of getting
there
obviously we you know he gave me the
best part of him and that's
and I'm thankful for the role he plays
and being a good dad because like he
helps
him and his stepdad helped me make a
child that will never even question what
kind of life that I even had
I wouldn't imagine ever hurting my child
in a million years
never mind like that
and it and that you know that also
brings me to my sister who like they
also think I'm the coolant I have a
niece and nephew that are like 18 and
19.
like they they deal with a mom that's
really unhealed and she yells at them
brings them back for like five seconds
with love dishes them out with more
violence and more angry and more
names about their dad who died and
it's like it never stops
the cycle never ends and it's because
every time I
go back to it I think of him
I did as far as even talking
to every single one of his victims
after I gave birth
I literally messaged all eight of my
friends that were the ages of like 8 to
12. that all had to deal with him the
descriptions have already looked like
the strategies he used to wrestle with
them and treat them like their daughter
and you know buy things for them and
a man doesn't even bat an eye on it
victims respond I mean a lot of them did
actually yeah a lot of them told me the
stories a lot of them
they gave me full descriptions I
obviously apologize
and I recently I went to a St Patrick's
Day party and and one of their moms was
there and she when we were little she
stopped She Stopped us from like talking
after that happened because she was one
of those parents that actually believed
it
and I like sat down and she at first
didn't remember me and I was like I want
to apologize to you
and she was like why are you apologizing
to me
and I was like
I wish I could have helped in like some
way you know I wish I would like I wish
I wasn't your daughter's friend you know
I wish I could have done something
so that maybe my sister could have not
had that experience so my friends didn't
have to say that their first time having
sex was my father
that's pathetic
and it's even more ironic because the
family that he has now that doesn't
believe me and just a wild thought like
what what makes you think that I enjoy
admitting that
I don't know anyone that would enjoy
admitting that like that's just our very
strange thing to just engulfing and even
now like even
make up some weird story about how I'm
delusional or how honest
we'll come back around
I'm not gonna come back around
you can't forget what happens my sister
can't forget what happens everyone just
forget what happens and then because you
forget you end up turning into a monster
that goes right back into the same
pattern
again and again
and again
until you burn every bridge you ever
have
I grew up alone
the internet raised me early 2000s
and
I raised me
my mom slept
my dad molested me
and
I raised myself
he was never home
was that good dad
and she deserved better
and even though I hate my sister I feel
so bad
sometimes I wish I wasn't born
then maybe my mom would have like had a
change of heart you know
but at that like moment of relief my
trusted or got maybe
instead of falling back into the same
pattern she could have trust her own gut
and just said no I don't really like you
like that
and now I can't even stand in the same
room as her
that sucks
I have this one rule about my son
is that I'll post his face online
at all and you know a lot of people
assume it's good like I either don't
want to show him or obviously the
dangers of like people seeing him
I guess like a little bit it has to do
with that but it's mostly because of his
consent
in society they talk about
you know women need to give consent just
people in general consent is very
important
and I obviously didn't have much of it
and my favor when I was little
so like I need him to know the dangers
of the internet whether he chooses to
put his image out there that is 100 up
to him he has that freedom as a person
but I need him to First understand it as
an individual because if I don't
demonstrate that respect for him how am
I going to have like how am I going to
expect that for him to do it to other
people
how am I going to expect that same boy
that I want to raise and and and be
proud of to demonstrate the same thing
unless I do it for him and show him that
kind ladder
and
I don't know
it's not that hard
but yet I still watch my sister like
suffer
I like watch her
deteriorate
I lost contact with my nephew or niece
because I said some Choice words to her
she posted his face online despite me
I did everything in my power to go
through Facebook to
prove that he was my son and prove that
I don't post him eventually I got it
down but
that led to her explaining to me on
Facebook and all of my you know Facebook
friends because I'm a tattoo artist that
I must have enjoyed my dad molesting me
and how much of a failure I am and
I will never be nothing
at the same story
of an unhealed child
and no matter what I can't hate her I
won't do it
because I forced myself to look at that
whole picture
the whole picture
same with my dad
I can't hate any of them because why am
I going to hinder my own growth
for these people to take advantage of
more of my time
more of my effort
IJ can't
as much as I love my family it's not
fair to myself
you know I spend my whole life wondering
why my mom abandoned me 18 years ago
why did my dad choose another woman you
spent all that time grooming me to be
like your mini wife
you know I'd unravel my own self in that
with my own relationships right I had to
watch my small child deal with the worst
of me
you know I finally met a good person and
married him and sometimes I don't even
feel like I deserve but I am now
I want to torture myself
I want to destroy everything I have
it takes an actual effort to give a
and no matter how many times I've had
that conversation with my sisters or
even when I tried to confront my dad
about it because I did
I 100 confronted that man for him to
for him to halfway tell me that you
don't understand your sister was more
the problem
she was like 13. you're a grown man
what do you mean and then quickly took
it away and stopped talking to me
you live your comfortable life in
Virginia
being the medicine man you are and all
those people think you're awesome
there's victims out here that's why
you're not allowed in Rhode Island
there's victims out here that you're
forgetting about
and you don't care
and sweats
I don't know
I always
I've never said the story out loud
because I feel like every time I do
people seem to make it my fault
and then when Donna talks to me
then it really feels like my fault
but all I want is for Reuben to go away
that's literally all I want
I want him to go away so
bad and I miss my nephew
I miss my sisters I've never really got
to exist
because they'll be stuck in trauma for
the rest of their life
I missed the part of me that had a
childhood
the best part is is that when Scott one
day sees this
he will never know what I felt like
I'll never know
what it feels like to be in a house so
dirty
and there's maggots in your macaroni
I mean you're really trying your best
to just eat in your mom's on a bench and
your dad's nowhere to be found
and that's all I honestly want
and I thought like you know maybe being
a tattoo artist
like I could take my sisters with me
and I realize that I can't heal for them
and that makes me even more angry
because I would love to carry the load
I would 100 percent
eat Donna's drama
if it meant her just moving
on and being a happier healthier person
if maybe she could actually see me and
not see him
because like I understand that
and I hate it
like I hate it I look just like him like
I joke with my husband all the time like
if we got DNA tests like fingers crossed
I'm not Mexican like it's a glimmer of
hope and I joke because like I'm like I
I don't want to look like him
no one jokes around and call me me high
I could cringe in my skin
every time
so like I totally get why she hates me
but God it's not fair that all these
people had to suffer and you get to sit
there and you're really nice
you know place in your house in Virginia
being important in your native life
why your daughter thinks I'm a liar
that's like the best part and probably
What Hurts the Most
is that my baby sister thinks I'm just a
straight-up liar
but granted I was a terrible teenager
I'll be 100 honest I was a I was a
garbage teenager
I didn't know how to deal with trauma I
didn't know what I was thinking I I
wanted love so badly from a place that
didn't exist which was myself
I was so preoccupied in destroying what
was around me because I didn't know how
to process it that like I forgot about
myself
I thought it wasn't worth a living for
so like I get it
but like to tell the truth
you're a grown man now
I it's it's a damn shame
and I'm sure a lot of those people they
don't really think about it but I carry
it
I think about it all the time
I think about the people that go through
their daily life and that's in the back
of their mind
or like when they find a new partner and
they ask about the times that they've
had sex like normal couples and that's
like a a wrench in their whole
story
because you how are you going to unpack
that how are you ever going to unpack
that
I feel responsible for it
and it's a shame
it's all like all I want is to just
raise my son and be a better person than
me
you know not have to do all this
searching and hunting
you know not have to find people that
actually care to listen you know
and not have to go through the remedial
Trials of like
maybe this person will still love me
even though I fear that they're gonna
leave me
after she died it brought me to my
genuine religion and I'll like
even though it was so horrible at least
you know I'll thank myself that I found
myself there
and like
I like being an honest
I like having no boundaries when it
comes to Gods you know and who am I to
tell you God isn't real
I have peace in knowing that like
maybe it's not God I grew up very
Catholic
so like
to me God is whatever you want it to be
whether it's yourself
or anything
as I got older I um
I once yeah I do I do like microdose on
mushrooms
because I kind of
I've been to the therapy I've talked it
out I love it I love crying I even
tattooed sensitive on myself to remind
myself that I'm still a little
being a tattoo artist didn't make me
tough just makes me cry even more
and like I don't know I I love it we'll
grind it up I'll it'll be obviously when
we're alone I usually have my dogs and
it's the one time where I could kind of
like dig out my own trauma and not be so
afraid of it
I used to be so afraid to just admit to
myself of this
and like actually expose it and let
people know like listen you're not alone
I totally get it you know
I understand what it was like to be to
be groomed by your own parent and then
search for that love that wasn't
actually stable
and then be ignored
that's probably the worst part the
people that ignored me and exiled me
like my stepmother
who also grew up abused as well
my step siblings I only found out that
they stopped talking to me
because uh my husband had we like went
to play pool and we went to this like
local bar and I walked in and I could
see my brother in like the distance and
like shoved my husband I was like that's
my brother and like because I've never
had a brother and one of my step-brother
and you know he was so nice and I could
see his face change
and he was very distraught and I was
like what's wrong he goes I I have to
tell you I mean they told me I didn't
have to but I I just want to let you
know that you really can't come to my
wedding
I was like oh oh okay I was like no I
get you
and he's like I just
when you made those accusations they um
they don't want trouble and they don't
want you there because obviously they've
you know I mean I'm not anything to do
with it and I was like no no listen it's
not my day
you have to understand that
I would never interrupt your day
it's not about me it's about you
I'm not gonna go there I you have
nothing to worry about it's not it's the
idea that now everyone thinks I'm this
monster
what made you not believe me
what made you not believe the other
eight to ten people
why are you believing this person
is beyond me
it's beyond me
oh
I now that I'm older I feel like it's
it's gotten a little easier to just I
don't know see my parents as the people
they are versus being my parents because
I feel like if I see them as my parents
I can feel the hate grow and that's not
what I want to harvest obviously
but like even my dad and like looking at
it now I'm
now I'm like seeing a bigger picture
because what what traumatized you as a
child to do this there's like this
documentary I saw on like Amazon and I
can't remember it but it was about this
this like fellow who had like a house
down south
and um his job
was to like give therapy to these like
child molesters or predators
and like I listen I as for someone who
has been there I completely understand
why people want to absolutely just X
them out of life
but that's not gonna actually just stop
people from that happening too you can't
you can't really do that you got to
really get to that core
and I kind of admired it and also sat
there a little bit and I would never
ever take
the troubles that this man has caused
from him
but it kind of let me wash my hands of
it and almost say like listen whatever
your God is you will 100 deal with that
but
I hope you find some kind of some kind
of reasoning as to why you're like this
whoever hurt you in life I am sorry for
that little version of you but that
doesn't excuse who you are now and the
same I feel like goes for everyone it
goes for my sisters it goes for my dad
it goes from my stepmom who'd allowed it
and it goes for everyone in between
you can't hold yourself back from the
traumas that you've had
but who you are and how you treat people
after is 100
your responsibility it is your
responsibility to make sure you heal so
you don't bleed on those people
I can't expect Scott to raise me I can't
expect him to to go through the same
things that I did just because of what
of sake of argument
I think that's not fair your job is to
be a better person
so at the end of the day you are someone
you could be proud of your children or
you know even your dog because I want my
dog to be proud of me not gonna lie but
like
it's not hard
I mean it's hard and it definitely sucks
but I mean isn't that what you have a
hundred years for why do you want to be
stunted in one place
why why do you want to walk around and
wake up one day and you're 55 and you
know you're still living in a remedial
little apartment that you've had that
you're not happy with in a town that you
hate with around the people that you
hate married to the person that you hate
with you know the kind of animals that
you don't like like there are so many
people live in such unhappy lives it's
like
why when's it your turn to actually be
happy can you take the time to actually
you know care about yourself
then I mean I guess that is a lot to ask
but
I got 100 years so why not start you
know
I guess this is my way of starting
because after this I hope he sees it
oh I do
I hope he sees it I hope my stepmom sees
it
I hope the victim see it
I did tell one of them about this
interview
and uh she actually married me
she was she was a good one
and um
she actually like lost her virginity to
my dad
so this was really important to her and
for us
and even though I hate my sister it's
for her too
it's for that little version of her that
I want to hug so hard and say
sorry
and it's for me who
you know just wanted her girlhood back
so I feel like it stops really being
about you know the story and more about
you know people and how they feel and
how they actually you know
progress in life I want everyone to
actually feel better about this
you know except him
you don't get to feel better about this
I don't think so sir
so if you do see it
good
thank you Richard thank you